today I'm gonna be talking about two
libraries that are very dear to me
pandas and scikit-learn I think they're
two of the more popular libraries in the
scientific Python ecosystem however
there is a bit of a problem when you go
to use them together and this this kind
of goes right to the hearts of the two
libraries and that's to their data
models so scikit-learn essentially uses
numpy arrays for pretty much everything
there's scifi sparse matrices which
we're not going to talk about today so
yeah so ii learned basically using numpy
Reis pandas builds on top of numpy
arrays but it has also made some
extensions so there's a ton of overlap
here you know I left out some features
but you know where pandas reuses numpy
things like broadcasting Becker
vectorization you funks pandas gets all
that from numpy however the extensions
that pandas is made to numpy things like
labelled arrays you know they get lost
when you try and go from pandas down to
something like scikit-learn
so this will show up if you fit a model
fit a linear regression or something and
then do model dot predict passing a data
frame you lose your row labels which is
unfortunate not the worst thing in the
world though you'll just wrap it up in a
data frame on the output what can be
more problematic is when you have
heterogeneous data so data frames can
store floats they can store a column of
integers they can saw our column strings
de times whatever you can have any
different combination of types within a
single data frame numpy race on the
other hand are homogeneous they can only
store a single D type for the entire
array doesn't matter how many dimensions
you have it's all just one D type so
that that can cause some problems
especially for for newcomers who maybe
don't know that gnome heart rates are
homogeneous if you try and plug in the
data frame to a second learn estimator
it's gonna cast it to an umpire array
and you can run into troubles also
pandas has implemented some mixed
d-types these are things like
categoricals and day times with time
zones and numpy just can't represent
these at all even if there are a single
homogeneous dimension numpy can't deal
with it so my claim to you which I don't
think is that outrageous is that the
data that you'll be interacting with day
to day is going to be labeled it's gonna
be heterogeneous and it's gonna be messy
which means you're gonna want to use
pandas like that's what it was built for
however pandas is just a tool it's a
very capable tool but it is just a tool
that you're going to use to reshape your
data and stuff before you hand it off to
matplotlib for visualization or second
learners that's models to do the actual
modeling so you need pandas but you also
need these other libraries that do the
useful stuff so the data we'll be
working with today is a pretty simple
little tips data set it comes from some
our package we can read it in here from
a CSV you can see we've got a total
build tip some categorical string
columns and also the size of the party
okay if you look at the info method you
get the D type so you can see we have a
mixture of floats an integer column and
then pandas represents string columns
this object so these are Python strings
and for our little practice example here
we're gonna predicting the tip column so
that will be our wire our outcome
variable our target and then our feature
matrix is going to be everything except
for that so it'll be the total bill sex
smoker daytime in size okay so this you
know isn't a talk about how to use
cyclic Learn really so we're gonna keep
thing as simple as possible just gonna
fit a linear regression okay so from SK
learned when your model import linear
regression model dot fit XY and we get
evaluator in the air really is extremely
clear right could not convert string to
float which yes that makes sense second
line thank you
looking at the stats right this is a
model that we're fitting y equal X is
our feature matrix beta is kind of the
hypothetical line that describes the
relationships between x and y so that's
a vector of coefficients and then some
error term
you actually go to estimate that model
if you haven't seen this before don't
worry at all like if you've done the
stats class you may have come across
this equation for how to find the best
fit line beta hat the only reason I put
it up there is because you're going to
be doing matrix multiplications so this
X transpose X inverse there's all a
bunch of matrix multiplications in order
to solve for beta you need to do matrix
multiplications okay which means you
probably need numbers and not strings so
scikit-learn is doing this for us just
an aside I found this really curious
exact same thing in our same data set
tips L M is linear model linear
regression and this is sort of syntax
for that and our just does it which i
think is awesome because we have these
two communities right where Python I
think most Python programmers are you
know explicit butter an implicit right
so they're fine with us and our
programmers are also fine with this and
I think that's great to two communities
completely different ways of handling
this problem but both are definitely
valid okay so we are using Python so
it's up to us to actually handle the
transformations going from the strings
to the numerix however we do that um one
way I often see suggested for doing this
is to factorize the columns and
basically what that does is it scans
through your categorical column of
strings or whatever and if it has not
seen this particular value yet so say
it's scanning through it hasn't seen
read yet it assigns it a first number of
0 keeps going it seen read again gets
another 0 and it's a new one purple so
now that gets the next one in the
sequence and so on all the way through
your data set okay so it's a way of
turning strings into numbers
this is implement in pandas as PDF
factorize that returns a tuple of toads
which are the numeric values and labels
which are the distinct ones like the
distinct like for day O's Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday so the distinct
values you can see the codes there so we
can apply this PDF factorize to each of
our categorical columns sex smoker day
and time using the apply function will
be a reply method will be basically
overriding these columns in this X
factorized just grabbing the first tuple
here first element of the tuple the
actual codes the numeric values so if
this doesn't make sense that's really
fine just realize that we've gone from
this string this column this data frame
with some four columns of strings and
now we have a data frame that's
completely numeric we can go ahead fit
our linear regression and you know that
succeeded we're looking at the
coefficients here and we're happy but
while we fix the numeric problem we made
some pretty bad statistical errors right
all of a sudden the ordering of your
rows is important because as PDI
factorize is scanning through here it's
saying okay I haven't seen this one yet
it's getting it's getting the next one
in the sequence but like one of the core
assumptions of linear regression is that
you can reorder your data at will and
this will happen like if you're reading
from a database or something where the
order of the rows isn't necessarily
guaranteed to be the same or if you're
doing like train tests split you could
end up with different ordering so that
is bad we can also have our categoricals
when we when we factorize we're
essentially saying that each category
each two pairs of adjacent categories
are equally spaced and with our linear
regression that has the added effect of
saying that the effect the change in Y
with respect to a change in X is the
same for any two pairs of adjacent
categories so we can kind of visualize
this here right we've got the x axis is
the days that happen to be in sunday
Saturday Thursday Friday order we have a
single unit between each one whatever
that unit is and we can only fit a line
right we're doing linear regression when
we have a single parameter where to work
with this is the best line but that
doesn't mean it's actually any good so
factorise is a no-go fortunately there's
a better solution which is dummy
encoding and that's actually what our
dead initially and what this will do is
it'll take your initial column and it'll
expand it out into several columns one
per distinct value in the original one
so in this case we have the four
distinct colors and the that gets
expanded out into four columns the
values in this expanded data frame array
is going to be a1 wherever that row was
equal to that value so in this case
the first one will have a 1 in the red
column and zeros everywhere else this
will have a 1 in the second the purple
column and the 0 everywhere else I
should say now so pandas this is
implemented as PD get dummies this also
has a drop first equal true keyword Arg
if you care about perfect
multicollinearity yeah
machine learning people don't seem to
care about that as much as like
economists I don't know why but we're
gonna ignore it today just for
simplicity of the code later but you
might want to use that drop first equal
true just saying ok so yeah we can use
this here the way we would do it is X
dummy's equal PD get dummies you just
pass in the original data frame looking
here it returns the numeric columns
through completely untouched just at the
start of the output data frame and then
it's gone through and expanded each of
our categorical so we have sex was
expanded sex female and sex male smoker
it's been its smoker no smoker yes and
so on so any questions on that on dummy
encoding okay that's the better way to
handle this so now we can we've
basically caught up with our we've done
our the the dummy encoding that our did
behind the scenes we can go ahead and
fit our regression we can get our
predictions and everything and we're
happy but that is a bit fragile so
ninety ninety-five percent of the time
I'm doing this that's exactly how I do
it I just do call Peter get dummies on
my data frame and fit the regression or
whatever I'm doing this applies equally
well to pretty much any estimator and
then just move on with my life however
if you're going to like productionize
this whatever that means you you might
want a few more features so first of all
it's a bit hard to go from dummy encoded
values here back to the original
categoricals if you're hoping to like
interpret your regression or whatever
you might want to be able to invert that
transformation the peterotica
get dummies by itself doesn't intergrate
very well with scikit-learn pipeline
objects i don't have time right now to
talk about those but there's a session
this afternoon about scikit-learn
pipeline so definitely check that out
for now all I can say is that you should
be using them if you're working with
larger than memory datasets you can run
into some pretty I I have run into some
pretty strange problems where right you
instantiate your estimator and
scikit-learn has this partial fit
basically API for working with memory
datasets that don't fit in memory I ran
into situations where the estimator is
going through chunks of my dataset and
one of my chunks happened to be missing
one of the distinct values so like we
could have a chunk where we only had
days Thursday Friday Saturday no Sunday
if you call PD get dummy's on a regular
column it'll just get expanded out and
we only have three now and that will
mess up your matrix algebra later on
because you're suddenly missing a column
that's bad and also very confusing and
finally memory efficient inefficient if
we have a bunch of Records relative to
distinct categories I'll talk about that
here in a second
well right now so the first step to
making this a bit more robust would be
to categorize the columns the
categorical columns so pandas 0.17 may
be implemented true categoricals so
these are like ours factors that tips
data set in our was actually using
factors and the way these work is you
store a it's a it's a one of those
extension D types I mentioned and you
store basically these set of distinct
values that it can take once so things
like the day of the week Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday you store those once and
then associate each one of those with a
numeric code so you can store those in
like a bit integer so then you have your
zero one two three representing which
day you're actually on so that's
extremely memory efficient but it's also
nice because you have the statistical
implications like you can't accidentally
put another day in there that doesn't
belong
you also get things like well yeah
ignore that but anyway so we've done
tips info now and you can see that we
have the the float columns here and the
category so this is the extension D type
here
all right the information that's stored
on the actual type itself so I should
say this is kind of porton this
information is stored on the type so if
you do something like take the first
five rows of our data frame like our
days seer you say it still knows even if
the I think the first five days are all
Sunday it still knows that the set of
possible values are Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday so it hasn't lost that
information if you're just doing with a
numpy array and you only see Sunday you
have no idea what other possible values
could be there okay so those categories
are stored on the type and the order is
also stored on the type and then for
this last bit I think we'll do this
hopefully do this life so this notebooks
up on github I tweeted out the link to
the slides earlier with the hashtag so
if you want to check that out you can
this is just going through everything we
talked about so far and getting to this
this transformer mixin that will write
so I'm gonna be kind of showing you a
real world example of how to write a
custom scikit-learn transformer that'll
do the dummy encoding and I'll have all
the things that we want it'll be well
obviously it'll be integrated with
pipeline objects because that's what
we're doing
it'll also be serializable to disk it'll
have some nice features like that but
the the overall takeaway like it's gonna
we're gonna get down into the weeds here
and that's okay but the high level goal
that I don't want you to lose sight of
is that it's not impossible to write
your own transformers if you need to and
you're gonna have this concrete example
to go back and look at later so the way
you write pipeline transformer mix-ins
is we'll call this a dummy encoder and
will inherit from transformer mixin okay
the interface that you need to satisfy
is you have to implement a fit method
that'll take an X which is our feature
matrix and a Y optionally we're not
going to use it here we'll do some stuff
here fill that in later and then we'll
return itself so the second piece of the
interface that you have to satisfy is a
transform method so again this takes x
and y optionally which we don't use and
we can do this one right now this will
just be get dummies I should say the ex
that we're dealing with is the
categorical version so we've already
done that okay see the D types there so
you implement a fit and a transform
method and just to simulate things so
this is how I write transform I might do
some type checking also but just to
simulate a later stage in the pipeline
that is only speaking numpy or wrap this
in an NPI as array to convert it from my
data frame to a numpy tray because
typically this is early on in your
pipeline you'll have like a psychic
learn like standard scaler or something
that will return an umpire array even if
you give a data frame I think so we'll
simulate a later stage in the pipeline
that is dealing with umpire raised by
wrapping it in the as array finally you
can if you choose implement an inverse
transform method this will take like the
transformed version and I think it takes
a Y and this whole this will do some
stuff later we'll fill it out so the way
this works is you say D this will be our
dummy encoder and we can say our
transform data set is going to be deed
Fitz transform so even though we didn't
implement fit transform we get that from
the mixin all this does is call fit and
then calls transform returning that
result and we'll pass in X here and we
don't need Y so tearin' window will be a
number rate so this is basically
identical to Peter docket dummies of X
without the columns without the
categorical information so so that's
back to where we were again and yeah so
I should reiterate again like if you're
just fitting a regression and you want
to like just check the coefficients or
something just use PDF yet dummies don't
don't bother with any of this but this
is more if you want to like persist it
to disk or something or use it in a
categorical so most of the time just use
the simpler version so the way pipeline
objects work is you basically you'll
record in for info I up in the fit
method and
use it in transform and inverse
transform so what do we need basically
we'll only be using it in inverse
transform because we've already done
we already not in transform step so this
method is going to be going back from a
numpy array to a panda's data frame and
to do that what information do we need
we'll definitely need the columns right
we've lost the column names so we'll
store that up and fit we've lost all our
categorical info so these are things
like the set of possible categories and
things like the order whether or not the
categories are ordered or not and we'll
also definitely need the kind of the
relationship between the original column
names going back and forth between those
and then the positions of the numpy
array so we've lost our labels so we
need to know what positions down here
belong to which column labels up above
sound good
all right this yeah we're getting into
it now so the first few aren't aren't
too bad so by convention we append a
trailing underscore to things that are
learned during the fit method so we'll
append I capture the column names with X
columns not too bad it might be useful
to know which are the categorical
columns easiest way to do that is to use
this select d-types method I'll show
that to you here so X not select the
types this can take a list of d types to
include or exclude so we'll include all
the category d types so it just gives
you a columns where the d type is
category and we'll store the columns do
that here and the non categorical
columns is going to be the original
columns and we'll drop those
self-thought cat calls and I type ode
self somewhere there we go okay so now
if we look at de we have these
attributes we can use later on we have
the categorical columns we have the non
categorical columns
so we'll make use of those in a bit so
the the next thing check that off the
list next thing we might want is the
categorical info so the easiest way to
get at these is if you look in the
original data frame if we look at like
they you can see it's a D type category
and it gives you a bit of info and all
of that extra categorical info is stored
under the stock cat access er so pandas
does it with things like the dots turn
aim space the dot TT namespace same
thing here for a dot cat
that'll hold references to the
categories which is the set of all
possible values and the codes which are
the numeric and numeric indices backing
it and then the ordered which is just a
boolean saying whether or not the
categories are ordered so we can just
store this dot cat thing in a dictionary
here on the instance itself so we'll
call that self dot cat map it's a
dictionary of categorical column to that
dot cat thing for call and self-thought
cat calls any questions so far
we've checked off the first two the
categories of the column names and then
the categorical info we haven't made use
of them yet though just a lot of prep
right now I'm gonna doing on time do a
fifteen minutes or so ten minutes I
think we're I think we're okay
so so we've recorded this intro sorry Oh
perfect we had tons of time any
questions
like seriously we're doing great on time
okay how are we doing so far
like have I lost more than half the room
awesome
okay well that's to be expected tray
alright so classes and all that so we're
gonna make use of some of this
information down here we can call PD dot
get dummies on X again just to see so
like I said before all of the numeric
columns are up front so they're the
first ones that are passed through
unchanged so we can grab those pretty
easily relatively easily initially so we
know that we have remember transform is
this
numpy array here we don't want every row
and we know we want the first two
columns right since that's how many
numeric columns we had how many non
categoricals of course in general it's
not going to be two it's going to be Len
of self non cat calls which is just the
non categorical columns so we'll grab
those first two and we'll wrap them up
in a data frame remember we're going
from numpy back to pandas here in this
inverse transform step and we'll make
sure to attach the column labels which
is going to be
we can't refer to X anymore
unfortunately right we lost that so
we'll have to use self dot non cat calls
okay questions on that so numeric ones
first two in this case
pass those get passed through by PD get
dummies unchanged so we just need to
wrap them up in the data frame so that's
the relatively easy part handling the
categoricals is a bit more work because
we need to we need to figure out first
of all which slice of transform do I
need to take to reconstruct that initial
categorical so I happen to know that xx
that categorical got expanded to columns
2 through 4 the slice 2 through 4 so 2 &
3 so I know that but how do I record
that information up and dot fit so that
I can use it later on in inverse
transform so the easiest way I've come
up with not the most straightforward but
I think it's maybe the best way to do it
is to know that we're basically in a
step through the original data frame we
know that we start out at 2 so looking
at the first categorical sex that starts
out at position 2 which isn't - in
general right it's going to be that Len
of self thought non cat calls again so
that's - in this case that's where we're
starting out first and then we're gonna
store this these slice info right that 2
through 4 and so on
in a dictionary we'll call it cat blocks
so I like the blocks of categoricals the
slices that you need to take and will
iterate over our
not our over our categorical columns in
self dot cat calls iterating over those
and we know that we need to step from
our left points to our right point which
is starting out at left will go in this
case two additional steps for sex right
how do we know it's two because that's
the number of categories that are in
there so when you do PD get cut get
dummies get dummies on xx that gets
expanded out from one column to two
because there are two distinct values so
in general it's not actually two it's
actually gonna be Lane of X dot X of
call so this particular column likes X
in this case cat categories which is
this thing that cat categories so the
length of that that's how many steps we
need to take for that particular
categorical um so that's our left and
our right end points and then in the
dictionary self that cat blocks will
store the slice object from left to
right and before I forget we need to
make sure to update our position but
I'll show you if you haven't seen this
slice whoops
non cat calls I need an underscore
somewhere
there we go so if you haven't seen that
slice thing before basically if you have
like the string ABCDE you can slice that
right with two to four using the regular
square brackets we've tried to like
define a function and you return ABCDE
of X you know a slice you can't pass in
F of 2 to 4 here that's a syntax error
you can only use those : and cert in
certain places in Python so the way to
get around that is you store slice 2
comma 4 so that just is sugar for that
colon syntax okay so that's and like
dictionaries is where you can't store
the 2 : 4 and
either so we're gonna store the two
through four Slice okay we have I think
all the components that we need to
finally build up our our categorical so
looking at transformed again we now know
that two through four is actually this
self dot cat blocks I called it D cat
blocks for sex so that was the slice two
through four so how do we get from this
array two-dimensional array to this
categorical basically so if you look
through we kind of said that those
original values got expanded out and it
got a one where that value of that row
was equal to the value and that column
basically that female column and it got
a zero everywhere else and so in the
second row it has a zero in the first
column because that's the column for a
female and has a 1 in the second column
because that's a column for male so we
need to know which column has the 1 or
in other words which column is the
maximum and the easiest way to get that
with numpy remember we have an umpire
right here is with the Arg max method so
that tells you which index location is
the maximum and we say over the first
axis because we're going through row by
row we're collapsing the first axis so
this will give us back an umpire array
of zeros and ones a zero here means that
the value is equal to female and a 1
means that it was equal to male and we
can see that here and I'm gonna call
this codes so we need to go from this
we're stepping towards it we need to go
from this numpy array we now have a
one-dimensional nope RA to this
one-dimensional categorical normally
when you're making categoricals if you
look at the constructor you pass in the
values and the categories if you want so
where values would be like female male
male and so on right
that's how you normally make a
categorical this won't work I'm not
gonna run it normally you have the
actual strings themselves in this case
we have the codes we're kind of going
the other direction so we have this
alternative constructor from codes which
you
guess what codes and then you have to
pass the categories which we fortunately
recorded up above right we have the we
call that cat map I think of sex thought
categories remember what that was that
was that xx that cat thing
so we stored that so now we can refer to
categories here and we can also pass in
the ordered value so de that cat map of
sex thoughts ordered okay so this I'll
actually run this gives back a
categorical which you can stick into a
series just like however you want okay
so we've gone from a two-dimensional
number array to enough one-dimensional
numpy array of codes and from that
one-dimensional known pirate codes to a
categorical object so we are in the
homestretch now if I can scroll up so
we'll store this list of series here and
then for each column and slice in that
self dot cat blocks remember that
dictionary of slices will iterate over
that thing we know the codes are going
to be the transform thing we actually
bring that up so that you can see it
it's definitely not for me so that I can
actually see what I did
we'll take that right so we're gonna
take this self dot cat or actually we
already have the slice so we can use
that and then we'll take the Arg max so
that's the codes check that off and then
we construct the categorical the cat is
going to be PT categorical dot Frome
codes passing the codes
Peppe don't need that training space the
columns sorry the categories are going
to be the self dot cat map which we use
down there not sex it'll just be the
call dot categories and then the ordered
is going to be self dot cat map of call
dot ordered ordered so that's a
categorical which I said you can stick
in a series so we'll append that
after wrapping it in the series
constructor making sure to pass along
the name which is call last thing we
have to do is to just stick these to the
numeric and then that list of series
together we'll do that with concat it
takes a list of data frame or series so
we'll stick those together into a list
concatenated along the first axis X
equal one and then concatenate all
that'll work what do you think how do
you feel we can run D inverse transform
on TR N and we get back our original
date data frame which should be equal to
X there's one D type issue it's a known
issue we're working on it this this is a
float whereas our int originally but you
can fix that later if you want but
that's like that's like you know the
high level or low level sorry that's
definitely a low level way of doing this
which you know it's it's like forty
lines of code not terrible again I
should stress if you're just fitting a
one-off regression just do this right do
linear regression called PD dot get
dummies move on with your day if you're
actually going to be deploying a
pipeline use this or you know better yet
write a library I would love it if a
library like this existed where you can
just import dummy encoder from whatever
and use it not have to worry about it
again there are few things we could fix
up here but that's that you know very
high-level that's how you'll be doing it
any questions on that why the code up
here like okay so I just say like are
there any questions I asked that and
then I immediately move on the question
yeah yeah we don't eat it
yes so I might add type-checking yeah so
that probably we can basically assert
that the you know for each column in the
categoricals assert that the categories
are actually the same I would probably
do that this is alive what do you expect
I'm like coding up here man yeah no I
would definitely do that just be safe
right yeah yeah so I think I couldn't
quite hear it but I think you're saying
didn't we lose we didn't record the row
labels anywhere and so we've lost those
yeah I think multi indexes would be fine
I would have to think about that though
and then for your first part the row
labels what if those are lost so we
actually can't use row labels because
this transform and stuff that's intended
to work on any data set so like even we
can record them but we can't like if we
come through with the test data set
that'll have different row labels than
our training data set the column labels
should be the same so though so we
recorded those but can't use any row
labels unfortunately well I mean we can
so one more call yeah question yeah yeah
yeah so the comment was shouldn't you be
shouldn't basically this step where I
categorize it be in a pipe line and it
definitely should I was just saving time
so this step should absolutely like my
basic rule is as soon as your data set
is in memory you should start using pipe
line objects so it'd be better to write
like a you know class categorical
categorize or something that inherits
from trance
Mixon and takes you pass into that the
actual categorical values I think that
was your comment okay yes yep yep yeah
yes yeah absolutely
yeah I agree a hundred percent you
should oh yes so the comment was it's
also going to be a bit wasteful
computationally to be read it like if
you're doing a bootstrap or something
you basically want to store that once
early on in the pipeline yeah definitely
okay so I'm gonna wrap up I just had
like two more slides that that
particular transformer like it doesn't
matter like that's not the point of this
talk the point of this talk is that you
you might want to be comfortable writing
these little shim layers between pandas
and scikit-learn like scikit-learn just
can't depend on pandas at this point
because pandas doesn't have a stable
capi
maybe someday pandas is you know
continuing to evolve wes is laying out
thoughts right now for what a revamped
pandas internals will look like so it's
it's gonna be moving further away from
numpy arrays which you know by itself
isn't great but hopefully the benefits
are gonna be worth it regardless so
we're gonna need more bridges between
the other pandas whatever tabular
community and the in dimensional array
community so it'll be you know pandas
will be providing the hooks to do that
but maybe for other libraries you'll
you'll need to write your own little
shims there so that's like the most
important thing there's you know be
comfortable with this other takeaways so
pandas has a lot of open issues if you
if you're interested you can contribute
we label our oh we would label all our
issues with tags of like expected
difficulty level expected effort level
that will be required how much knowledge
you need so so if you are interested in
contributing yeah sign up for the
mailing list if you're interested in the
internals refactoring and then check it
out on github alright with that I think
I'm done thank you
yes I think five minutes if there any
additional questions not yeah is the
notebook available yet on github and
yeah it's on my github Tom augsburger
and it's called slash MTG is the name of
the repo so the github the notebook is
up there I'll commit this one that I
just did and then these slides I'm not
on Wi-Fi but yeah and I tweeted it out
as well under the conference hashtag all
right thank you